when he goes out and actually deploys to
chase something it looks like a missile
launch
i just opened up the back door and he
jumps out it's a lot of fun
piper is the only dog working at this
airport and there's actually only a
handful of dogs working at airports
around the country it's a pretty rare
thing
i'm brian edwards piper and i work at
the cherry capital airport in traverse
city michigan
piper is a border collie
piper's prime function here is wildlife
control
primarily a piper is going to be chasing
away large waterfall like ducks and
geese in the wintertime that actually
chases away the snowy owl and then in
the summertime it's basically seagulls
and crows
birds can cause a lot of different types
of damage most bird strikes are with
smaller types of birds that might just
cause dense but if the bird is large
enough and is ingested into an engine
that can cause a serious failure like
the miracle on the hudson
[Music]
training specifically for us took about
a year year and a half
so the way that we've trained is that
anytime i deploy piper out of the truck
he doesn't just run away from the truck
he always runs the direction we were
traveling a lot of times i deploy him
when the vehicle is moving
so that's just the way that we train
that a lot of times i try to get him to
see what it is he's going to chase first
the goggles or the rec specs serve two
purposes for him one they're uv
protectant so they protect his eyes and
number two there are safety goggles
basically it's one of those things if he
wants to go out and work or have fun
then he's got to wear it
dogs are really useful for wildlife
control because uh specifically border
collies it's in their blood eventually
the goal is to
train the birds and other animals that
they don't want to be here because
there's a predator in town something
that's going to keep harassing them all
the time
piper's been with me at the airport for
almost three years he's pretty much with
me all the time i don't think piper sees
it as work i think it's all play to him
well which is what we want right
the best thing personally with piper and
it's been this way before we started
working
he's got a mind of his own i talk to him
like i would talk to anybody else he's
my bro it doesn't get any better than
that i get to work with my best friend
every day i'm extremely proud of him i
couldn't ask for anything more
[Music]
you